all of us want to protect anonymity
online what we want to tackle is
anonymous abuse and I make that
distinction we'll go on and and and and
develop that so I the first thing I want
to say is when this when online first
happened I was with Jamie 100% I thought
this is fantastic it facilitates
Democratic participation
it allows us to hear voices that you
could never hear before and I really
really you warmly warmly supported I was
an advocate for it and then um I started
having my own experience of it and if I
just say to you that in a particularly
when I fought um anti-Semitism so I was
fighting racism in the labor party in a
two-month period uh when the uh report
was published on anti-Semitism in the
labor party by the ehrc and then there
were all the comings and goings about
Jeremy Corbin's position in that two
Monon period from October to December I
don't look at my own online abuse
anymore that an organization monitors it
for me Community security trust
brilliant organization I had 90,000
mentions 990,000 in two months uh of
which the majority were abusive and I
just want to share with you then I'm
going to go on because it's not just
about it's clearly not about me but that
brought me into
the sort of things that could go online
so for example why has half of 1% of our
population got so much power rid us of
this cancer that was uh Jews um I'm
called a Zionist Beach a Zionist stouge
aasa is appropriate as Israel is a
fascist State and then I'm going to read
one which might uh uh touch some
sensibilities I want her to feel
despised it's what the deserves
I so hope somebody kills her I really do
she's a lying deceitful hateful
who needs to be executed publicly so we
can watch and laugh at her the only
support she deserves is a handrail to
climb the Gallows the vile
so it's horrible and it's not just that
that's the sort of racism that I have
faced it's really for children and for
young people we know that um young
people particularly there's an increase
in suffering of mental health problems
from what they get there's been a
massive increase in self harm and in uh
suicide and in sexual exploitation all
those issues now you can't actually say
that there's a a a a there's a
correlation between the two but you
can't you know it you can't sorry you
can't cause it causal um uh relationship
between the two but you can say that
there's a correlation between the
increase in those uh in those issues and
uh the growth of young people using
online then you have things like uh the
racism we saw that with a Euro 2020
final where over 2,000 uh abusive
messages posted there using the nword
and uh using monkey um uh Ando as well
then you've got misinformation the antia
the people who talk about uh uh things
like dle uh solving all the problems of
Corona virus then you've got fraudulent
uh all the fraudulent advertisements
that are on there that uh uh get people
into absolutely a pooring financial
trouble and losing money and you've got
hate crime so there's a massive massive
massive it is a real problem Jamie and
we have to tackle it you can't just push
it to one side and nobody is pretending
that that tackling Anonymous abuse will
get rid of all abuse of course it won't
it's not but it's an important I think
ingredient in it just talk a little bit
about public opinion most of the public
now think in a recent uov poll four out
of five
78% people favored requesting users of
platforms to disclose their real
identity so there is some support for
there is a great support for it among
the public and the other thing to talk
talk about which I only recognized when
I started getting involved in the issue
is actually the business model of the
platform is based on there being a lot
of abuse traffic because the more abuse
there is online the more people watch it
therefore the greater the traffic
therefore the more they can uh uh get
from their ad uh from demands for
advertising uh from those who want to
advertise on the platform so the
business model
depends on allowing and not getting rid
of online abuse and I think that's
really important as to why should there
be government intervention this isn't
something that'll resolve itself because
it's not in their interest to do this
and can I just say something else which
I think is really important I don't know
you know here I was a great supporter
and promoter of anonymity then I start
getting this horrible stuff and actually
what it is it that what people try to do
through Anonymous abuse is paint you as
a vile awful person so for me I'm a
pedophile I'm a tax avoider I uh have
I've killed Palestinian children those
are the sort of things that are said
about me online and therefore they
undermine my credibility when I talk
about anything I could talk about
royalty I could talk about tax which I
try to talk about a lot but because I'm
a horrible person that can't be dist
trusted uh there is no credibility in
what I say so my own freedom to
participate in a democratic forum is
therefore undermined by the way that the
abuse undermines me personally and I
think that's an important thing to hold
in in in her so I'm do support anonymity
I think it's hugely important for the
sort of issues that Jamie talked about
but for victim of domestic violence
children who want to go on anonymously
been victims of child abuse I think it's
hugely important for whistleblowers all
of that what I want to tackle and as we
develop this evening manvi and I hope it
becomes clear what I want to tackle is
online abuse and I think there is a way
in which you can maintain anity but
start to tackle that online
abuse we'll come to David in just a
second um Margaret you talked about
credibility there and how damaging it
can be um I wonder if before we move on
you could just sort of give people I
know you have an organization that
filters some of the content that's
coming towards you but could you just
talk people through what it feels like
to be at the bottom of one of those
pylons for like the course you know over
the course of 24 hours what does it do
to a
person oh that's such a difficult
question because you have to learn to
understand that it's not the real me
that they're attacking and if I wasn't
able to do that to distance myself as
who I am you know what I care about what
I value what my friends think about what
my interests are if I couldn't do that I
think I'd be destroyed so I think that's
a a technique I've learned in politics
they don't this isn't the real me that
this isn't who I am that they're
attacking it's it's a sort of you know
it's a false uh view of my Persona so
that's one thing but the other thing I
would say to you is actually at the
height of this ab and I'm still getting
it I still every time I say anything I
get tor of abuse uh what it it makes you
very suspicious I think that's the main
thing is I'll walk into a room and
whereas I would have previously I'm a
quite outgoing friendly sort of person
being being confident there I tend to
look around me and think who's on my
side who's here to attack me and that's
something I never did before and I do
think twice about when I put stuff on I
do think I mean I have to you have to be
brave to do it man being and the only
way you I I won't let them defeat me
beat me but equally I sort of do it by
trying to say it's not the me they're
talking about horrible though at it is
and I didn't read out to you some of the
most awful vile stuff that I get it's
really it wasn't the worst I can't
imagine how much worse it gets um David
where do you stand on the question of
online
anonymity well I wouldn't ban it um but
I would suggest that there's a lot
platforms could be doing to reduce its
misuse and restrict the ability of
anonymous accounts to do harm and I
think there are three obvious things
which all the platforms could be doing
um the first is offer all their users a
right to verify themselves if if they
choose to do so most of the platforms
offer that to a sliver of their users um
some of us got a Blue Tick by our by our
Twitter profiles or whatever but that's
a very elite option at the moment I
would offer transparency to all you as
to who has chosen to verify and who
hasn't so we can make our own mind up
about what that says about The
credibility of what they're what they're
saying we're always exhorting people to
check the sources think critically about
the sources but we deprive them of that
key bit of information at the moment and
finally I would give each user more
choice and control over the extent to
which they see content and interact with
unverified accounts so though no knowing
that um Anonymous accounts are more
likely to to be AB abusive um that's
different people have a different
appetite for for for for taking that
risk and you should give those choices
um now I don't think that's not a Magic
Bullet it wouldn't solve all abuse um
for some of the reasons Jamie has
mentioned but I think it would make a
huge difference um we've we studied
clean up the internet the the way in
which anonymity is misused um and it
tends the difference between um benign
uses of anonymity and harmful ones tend
to around two behaviors which those
proposals that I've just outlined would
Bear Down on the first is abuse abusive
use of anonymity often it's un it's
about unsolicited communication it's
communication that people don't want to
hear so give people that extra control
secondly it's about deception and
inauthenticity it's not just that people
are hiding their identities it's that
they're deceiving people about who they
are so again make it more transparent
transparent people but by making those
underpinning all of that by a voluntary
right to right to verify you don't shut
out those legitimate uses people can
still build a following can still engage
online
with W with the choice to remain
anonymous it's clearer to people who is
anonymous and who isn't and everyone can
make their own mind out how much they
want to interact with those accounts now
Jamie mentioned one study of and he
quite rightly highlighted that anonymity
isn't the only factor that makes people
Nast you online but there's been a lot
of studies since and there's a lot of
evidence of is a really significant
factor recently UK internet users who'
suffered abuse to asked to report whatev
what level of act came from Anonymous
accounts and it was in in the 70s over
70% of UK victims of online abuse
reported that coming from Anonymous
accounts another study on Twitter which
you know random control study where they
gave some users um Anonymous Twitter
handles and some named ones and asked
them to engage in sexist content found
not only were the anonymous ones more
likely to retweet sexist jokes but they
were then more even more alarmingly
likely to act in a more sexist and
discriminatory way offline having the
practice that behavior online so this it
has a real impact on how people behave
um and really what the way I would frame
this is that anonymity is a risk factor
and it's one which platforms make
choices about how they manage through
their design and Margaret touched on the
the the question of the business model
at the moment platforms aren't designing
their approach to anonymity with a view
to maximizing freedom of expression or
safety they're designing their platforms
with a view to maximizing their profits
and
the the kind of measures that I'm
suggesting simply aren't incentivized by
an advertising business model which is
seeking to maximize attention and
maximize engagement and maximize user
numbers um it introduces friction it
sheds a bit of light on how much their
account the account numbers that they
can claim to advertisers are inflated by
inauthentic accounts and this is where I
think we need to not leave those kind of
decisions in the sole control of of
these platforms they're too much of a
Public Square but it to be left to that
and that's that's where independent
regulation the introduction of some
social obligations onto those platforms
to manage risk factors like anonymity
more responsibly that's that's where
we've got to get to which I'm not saying
it's easy but I think it is
possible Jamie um it from David's
analysis there it sounds like it is
having a more toxifying effect um than
than we'd previously
thought can we really manage with with
no you know with with complete anonymity
now I mean how how do you sort of answer
the the sort of experiences that
Margaret's had and the the abuse that
people are facing how do you how do you
get around that well um yeah I'm I'm
always horrified to hear the sort of
abuse that people like Margaret gets so
I obviously never want to defend that
the question is always to me the extent
to which a significant difference would
be made and the costs that would come
with that but David's suggestions seem
to be somewhere in the middle so we're
not talking about banning it entirely or
you know preventing people who need to
remain anonymous online on social media
from doing that but rather making it
slightly easier for people to see what
they're doing and who's Anonymous and
who's not
and the reason it matters is partly
because we we we don't talk enough I
don't think about the positives that
that the ability to be anonymous at
certain times does
bring we've got to talk as well about
the importance of of encouraging a free
and open internet all around the
world regimes are closing down on the
idea of a free and open internet and it
always comes down to the same thing make
people be forced online to show who they
are to give their documents over to have
all of their behavior monitored and we
need to not move in that direction so
where we can find some Middle Ground
where it helps people be slightly more
critical en encourage us users to work
out what different people are doing then
I'm I'm definitely behind talking about
that and working out how that can
operate but for example the case of the
racist abuse of football players in on
Twitter following Euro 2020 the
overwhelming majority according to
Twitter anyway of those accounts were
identified we should chat about that
jie and so much of that abuse comes from
non-uk accounts so my question is always
how are we going to deal with the
overwhelming majority or the the
insignificant amount of online abuse
that doesn't come from this country how
do we stop that from happening because
that there a lot of there's a lot of
nodding of heads going on in the in the
other direction so I'm going to go to um
Margaret first okay I just to deal with
a Twitter point I wrote to Twitter and
said could I have the basis for their uh
um their survey and they have refused to
share it with me I just don't think uh
you you can look at that as a legitimate
finding you know just to say to you JB
really and I'll share that whoops I'll
share that that correspondence uh with
you if if that's helpful I don't
actually go along with David as he knows
I don't go along with David's solution
uh entirely although I'm trying to find
a different little way the reason I
don't go along with David's solution is
twofold first of all I don't I want to
see I don't see why that the only way in
which I can protect myself is to say
I'll only talk to people who aren't
Anonymous who share their identity I
don't want that I want to deal with an
anonymous uh people who you know I do
want whistleblowers to contact me I do
want victims of domestic violence and
child abuse to be able to contact me I
don't want to shut that off because they
don't do that and the second argument
against David's solution is that
actually the police I'm obviously in
touch with the police quite a lot manded
because of the nature of the abuse I get
and the police say the worst thing you
can do if you're trying to identify a
real threat to you individually and I
accept that that is I mean it isn't as
remote as we thought as we saw with the
tragic death of David Amos but the worst
thing you can do is cut off the uh the
traffic that you're getting the online
you've got to know so that they can
judge whether or not it's serious so I
don't agree with that let me put forward
my middle way which I know David knows
but I haven't shared with Jamie I think
what we should do is anybody who goes on
a platform should actually reveal the
identity not to the platform Jamie not
to the platform um although they know
all about us because we know that from
the what the advertising that they throw
at us all the time but not to the
platform to a third party provider
uh uh and it's perfectly technically
feasible uh we could use something like
the banks the banks already know 99% of
people who who uh bank that would give
you the adult population that perfectly
so it's perfectly okay and you are
anonymous online I want everybody to be
anonymous and the only time when you
then uh give up your right to anonymity
I think it's a right is if you engage in
abuse against other people and at that
point the police in pursuing illegal IL
illegal harm online or me wanting to
pursue a civil uh uh a civil case
against somebody who abuses me would
have the right not to go to the platform
but the platform would then get it from
the third party so the platform hasn't
got the details the third party has and
I have the right to access that or the
police do uh if and when there's uh if
they're harmful abuse and link to that
two other things that have to go with it
at the moment that the law in relation
to online harms is too limited and
actually Nadine Doris made a statement
over the weekend where she tightened up
and introduced three new uh uh she's
going to introduce on the online harms
Bill three new offenses which would make
it much tougher and would make it much
more difficult for example to have
revenge porn to have a promotion of
suicide to have actually sexual
exploitation people smuggling all that
stuff would be then uh created as a
criminal offense and that's really
important so I really welcome what she
did I should say manv that this debate
is not a partisan debate that you know
I'm working on a cross-party uh uh basis
with other people and then the final
thing I want to say is I think because
of the way this this is a business model
the online platforms no good finding
them zilli because that just becomes a
business cost against their business uh
against their business and they're
making so much money they you know even
that what we're talking about wouldn't
hurt them harm them that much I think
you have to get director liability and
responsibility into uh uh the legal
framework that we would do for for uh um
monitoring and and regulating online
harms uh and I do this for my tax you
know my tax Justice work that it's no
good getting at the corporations that
doesn't change no good getting at the
banks no good getting at any of these
people because that simply doesn't
change their behavior if you introduce
individual director liability where they
break the law so with these new offenses
where they don't take stuff off that
could do all this massive damage then
they are individually liable so I would
it's a different solution to David's but
I think it's the only one that is
sustainable but I accept with Jamie I
want to protect anonymity but if you're
going to do that you have to deal with
the online
Harms